REVEALED LAST WEEK, THEY SHOWED
JUST THAT.
THIS WAS THE ONLY JUSTICE THAT
COULD HAVE BEEN HANDED DOWN.
HERE NOW, A MAN WHO WAS WITH
FLYNN FROM THE CAMPAIGN TO
TRANSITION AND WHO SAT
FACE-TO-FACE WITH MUELLER, RUDY
GIULIANI.
TODAY SEEMED TO SIGNIFY THE REAL
BEGINNING OF THE UNRAVELING OF
THE DEEP STATE AS WE KNOW IT, DO
YOU AGREE?
>> I BELIEVE IT’S A VERY
IMPORTANT DAY.
JUSTICE HAS BEEN DONE FOR A MAN
WHO HAS BEEN TREATED TOTALLY
UNJUSTIFIABLE WAY.
THIS IS A MAN THAT THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WAS OUT TO GET
FROM THE TIME THAT HE WOULDN’T
LIGHT FOR THEM AND IT HAD
SOMETHING TO DO WITH HIM AND IT
HAD SOMETHING TO DO WITH THE
FACT THAT THEY KNEW THEY WERE
TRYING TO FRAME TRUMP AND THEY
DIDN’T WANT TO FLYNN IN THE WAY,
THEY WANTED HIM OUT BECAUSE THEY
THOUGHT HE WAS THE ONLY ONE THAT
WOULD UNDERSTAND THEIR TRICKS.
CALL ME WAS SAYING HE WOULDN’T
HAVE TRIED THIS ON A MORE
EXPERIENCED ADMINISTRATION AND
THEY WANTED FLYNN OUT OF THE WAY
BECAUSE THEY KNEW THEY WERE
GOING TO CARRY OUT STRZOK’S
INSURANCE POLICY TO REMOVE
ILLEGALLY A SITTING PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
THESE PEOPLE ARE TERRIBLE
PEOPLE, IT’S ONE OF THE WORST
THING THAT’S HAPPENED AND THEY
SHOULD BE PROSECUTED FOR
CONSPIRACY.
>> Laura: DOCUMENTS RELEASED
REVEALED, SOMETHING VERY
INTERESTING.
OBAMA KNEW ALL THE DETAILS OF
THE WIRETAP TO FLYNN AND
SERGEY KISLYAK.
THIS WASN’T SURPRISING.
REMEMBER WHEN THEY SAID HE HAD
TO BE KEPT IN THE LOOP, REMEMBER
THAT MEMO?
>> YOU’RE NOT SURPRISED, ARE
YOU?
I’M NOT SURPRISED.
>> Laura: I’M NOT.
>> FLYNN OUTED OBAMA YEARS
BEFORE WHEN OBAMA WANTED HIM TO
LIE ABOUT ISIS.
FLYNN KNEW WHERE THE BODIES WERE
BURIED.
HE WAS A DANGEROUS MAN AND IT
ISN’T JUST TO GET TRUMP, IT’S TO
FACILITATE THEIR ATTEMPTS TO GET
HIM, THEY WANTED FLYNN OUT OF
THE WAY.
THEY HAVE ACCEPTED IT BEFORE, ON
THE RIDICULOUS FOREIGN AGENTS
REGISTRATION ACT CASE AND THEY
HELD ONTO THE CASE, THEY HELD
ONTO THE CASE, THEY NEVER REALLY
PROSECUTED IT BECAUSE THEY
ACHIEVED THEIR OBJECTIVE BY
LEAKING IT.
BUT THEN WHEN MUELLER CAME IN
AND HE HAD WEISSMANN AROUND WHO
WOULD PROSECUTE A LITTLE BABY OR
ANYTHING IF THEY HAD TO DO WITH
TRUMP, THAT WAS PROBABLY THE
STUPIDEST THING THEY DID.
THEY HAD ACHIEVED THEIR
OBJECTIVE WHEN THEY GOT HIM
FIRED.
>> Laura: HERE IS HOW
ADAM SCHIFF RESPONDED TO THE DOJ
DROPPING THE CASE.
>> WE LOST 50 YEARS WORTH OF
GROUND AND SOLIDIFYING THE
INDEPENDENCE OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AFTER WATERGATE, THIS
IS BACK IN THE CATEGORY OF AN
EMERGING DEMOCRACY WHERE THE
RULE OF LAW IS NOT YET FIRMLY
ESTABLISHED WERE PROSECUTORIAL
DECISIONS ARE MADE ON THE BASIS
OF POLITICS.
IT GETS BACK TO THE RUDY
GIULIANI TRUTH ISN’T TRUTH,
KELLYANNE CONWAY ENTITLED TO
ALTERNATE FACTS WORLD THAT
DONALD TRUMP LIVES IN.
>> Laura: SINCE ONE HAS
ADAM SCHIFF BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT
THE TRUTH?
>> I THINK ADAM SCHIFF IS PART
OF THE CONSPIRACY TO UNSEAT A
LAWFULLY ELECTED PRESIDENT.
LIGHTING FOR TWO YEARS,
MISREPRESENTING HE HAD MATERIAL
EVIDENCE WHICH HE DIDN’T HAVE,
WE TAKE A GOOD LOOK AT THAT
WHISTLE-BLOWER, IT’S GOING TO
TAKE YOU RIGHT BACK TO THE
BEGINNING.
YOU KNOW THAT.
ADAM SCHIFF HAS BEEN INVOLVED IN
THIS FROM THE BEGINNING AND SOME
OF THEM ARE EASY.
COMEY AND STRZOK AND PAGE,
POSSIBLY CLAPPER AND BRENNAN BUT
DID IT GO AS HIGH AS OBAMA AND
CAN YOU GET SHIFT?
THOSE OF THE TWO BIG QUESTIONS.
I THINK HE’S BEEN A PART OF THIS
SINCE THE BEGINNING.
>> Laura: THANK YOU SO MUCH,